what you doing hey
hey
how's pokey this morning
how are you doing baby cookie yeah
oh my goodness look at that little face
look at that little face
yeah oh my goodness oh my goodness
yeah
i wanted a bridge under the bridge
[Laughter]
it's like yep and then i'm just gonna
lay here it's like look happened there's
my knee and there's her guy
yeah oh my goodness
you are such a sweet baby you are just
such a sweet baby
yes you are
he's a sweet little baby yeah
yeah you getting my running shoes
okay what why are you eating that while
you eat in a box why are you eating a
box though she also eats everything
she's like a little goat you're like a
little goat
you know that
yeah
you can't help it
okay that's just how you do i know
that little stuff is just constantly
wagging
yeah
you're gonna eat mama's sheep you can't
eat mama's shoe oh look
uh
here comes the other one here comes
beigers
she wants in on the action too
she wants in on the action what do you
think about that pokey
what do you think about that
you don't think much of it do you i can
tell by the look on your face
uh-oh uh-oh
confrontation
conflict conflict
oh
a peaceful resolution uh well not now
because oh she can't resist it
she can't resist it
what are you guys gonna do
what are you guys gonna do
nothing
it looked like oh pokey oh pokey
acting casual thank you
okay
you didn't even swipe up beijing's butt
what a good girl you are
[Laughter]
what a good girl you are
beijing wins this round